everybody Abby Jacobson is here and it
is time
[Applause]
you're going to tell me three spicy
facts and I'm gonna guess which one is
the lie and if I get it wrong I have to
share a spicy fact about myself okay
okay we've never played this before this
is the first all right round one both of
my parents are artists
Questlove was a fan of Broad City before
Amy polar
Kelly Ripa makes her own moonshine and
was the inspiration behind her drinking
it on Broad City
now this is not because I don't think
Kelly Ripa is the coolest and like maybe
makes her own moonshine but I went with
the true on Quest lab because he was a
part of like the birth of Hamilton like
he's super on the pulse about things
he's always ahead of the game in front
of everybody else so that was my guess
am I correct
you got them right
all right round two
I committed light fraud at the MoMA
using my greeting card line
that was called imagine that
I'm sorry I'm laughing at the title of
my greeting card company I hope that's
what you're doing because that now
sounds very suspicious does it I'm on
Darcy cardin's Hall Pass lists
oh
Alana Glazer and I Cyber Bullied Whole
Foods so that we could shoot there
[Applause]
B is the lie you got it again
Alana asked me to name her baby the last
time I was Starstruck was this moment
my childhood celebrity crush was
Jonathan Taylor Thomas
B is the LIE
uh no what and I didn't name Alana's
baby
oh
oh
all right well then I guess I have to
tell something about myself I have to
reveal something I right now am keeping
a food blog I don't know if that's
private but I just realized that now I
had pizza for lunch and a hot dog for a
snack so that's today's food Vlog are
you keeping a food log because you want
to be more aware of what you're eating
because I'm having some intestinal
issues
well that's what they that's what they
ask you to do right so you can like see
what you're eating and then what bothers
you yeah and today's food Vlog is super
humiliating
I have loved you for so long I love
everything that you've put out into the
world and as fans of the film you really
took a legacy and did make it your own
which is so impressive to do and I heard
you got Penny Marshall's blessing I'm
such a fan of yours have been forever
that just means a lot to me but yes we
talked to will and I will Graham who who
I made the show with got a chance to
talk to Penny Marshall right before she
died and and just told her you know we
love like I love the movie so much we
were in no way trying to remake this
thing that she made that we all love but
we were we were really wanting to open
it up and tell a lot more stories and
and she gave us her blessing and she she
was like no go do it already don't do it
and you do you really fill in a lot of
the story lines that were not in the
movie that are very much a part of this
history yeah so I commend you for that
and I just love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]